Castle followed a tried and true TV
formula Nathan Fillion starred as crime
novelist Richard Castle and Stana Katic
played homicide detective Kate Becker
the two mismatched characters and
probably paired up to Safe crimes in New
York City though Kate initially resented
Castle being around the Romantic tension
between the two couldn't be ignored and
they struggled a romantic relationship
behind the scenes Sparks also flew but
in a bad way in 2015 tension supposedly
came to a head and katik suddenly exited
the show after eight seasons as one of
the leads there were rumors of Philly
and demanded should be written off the
show though his only public statement
about the situation was a 2016 Twitter
post in which he thanked Katic and
wished her well in a 2018 interview with
Entertainment Weekly Katic finally
opened up about her firing saying I'm
actually still not clear on the thought
process behind the way it went down it's
hurt and it was a harsh ending ABC
canceled Castle in 2016 before a
cataclyss ninth season could be made